[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 26 janvier
voici les titres
une hausse de 10% des barème
d'indemnités kilométriques c'est le coup
de pouce annoncé par le gouvernement
face à l'envolée des prix du carburant
une flambée qui impacte largement le
quotidien des automobilistes vous le
verrez et xavier de la porte président
du club climat énergie de saint quentin
en yvelines sera également notre invité
pour parler des alternatives à la
voiture traditionnelle
la start up a été lancée en 2020 à
louveciennes art et cosy et spécialisée
dans l'ameublement et la décoration
d'intérieur à l'an passé elle a
poursuivi son développement grâce à
l'accompagnement du réseau entreprendre
avec le lancement d'un site internet
focus et puis c'est une salle de concert
bien connue des yvelinois la batterie de
guyancourt dispose également de trois
studios de répétition ils sont
accessibles aux professionnels mais
aussi aux amateurs à la location
découverte
avant de développer ces titres à un
yvelinois en lice aux césars à 2022 samu
ou tal ben ali est nommé dans la
catégorie du meilleur espoir masculin
pour son rôle dans une histoire d'amour
et de désir réalisé par leïla bouzid le
natif de poissy joue ahmed un jeune issu
de la banlieue parisienne qui
rencontrent lors de son premier jour de
fac une étudiante venue de tunisie il en
tombe éperdument amoureux mais va tenter
de résister à ce désir samule tabally et
est en lice avec quatre autres comédiens
dans la catégorie réponse le 25 février
lors de la 47e cérémonie des césar 2011
[Musique]
le carburant n'a jamais coûté aussi cher
en france le prix d'un litre d'essence
sans plomb 95 et est d'un euro 72
centimes en moyenne la semaine dernière
celui du gazole de 1,65 euro c'est 20
centimes de plus que fin 2018 lorsque
des protestations contre la hausse des
prix du carburant avait justement
déclenché la crise des gilet jaune
réaction au chesnay grand concours et à
voisins le bretonneux avec mathilde
franco
jusqu'où les prix du carburant
grimperont t-il la facture pour les
automobilistes ne cesse de gonfler des
records sont battus tous les jours
depuis le début de l'année la hausse
atteint 26% sur un an pour le gasoil et
21% pour le sans plomb 95 les prix ont
largement dépassé ceux de fin 2018 début
du mouvement des gilet jaune et dans les
yvelines la hausse des prix se fait
également ressentir pense qu'on fasse de
blanc régulier comme ça bah tu en as
rien que pour 60 et j'ai même pas le
plan donc ça fait bah ça fait pas du
bien avant j'étais
10 10 centimes moins cher même la
discount elle est beaucoup plus chère
maintenant et moi force de faire des
allers-retours oui c'est à dire une
bêtise 50 balles de plus par par mois
environ voire plus tout dépend de
comment je roule mais en général les
serveurs je préférerais le mettre
ailleurs un peu dans l'essence dans les
loisirs mais
enfin même pour faire des courses à la
limite je préfère consommer pour manger
que consommer pour rouler c'est toujours
un peu saint cast est maintenant de
rouler en voiture ça devient difficile
alors où trouver l'essence la moins
chère dans les yvelines grâce au site
mon quart du point comme nous avons
réalisé un comparatif dans le nord des
yvelines le total access relais de la
couture h au four les bonnes hier est
l'une des stations services les moins
chers du côté de saint quentin en
yvelines et de versailles grand parc ce
sont les stations bp attrape auchan à
plaisir ou encore leclerc à bois d'arcy
qui seront à privilégier et dans le sud
des yvelines le supermarché auchan de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines affichent des
prix bas ce contexte profite au
bioéthanol ce carburant vert est
composée jusqu'à 85 % d'éthanol à partir
de blé de maïs ou encore de betteraves
sa consommation a augmenté de 33 %
l'année dernière la hausse des prix des
carburants a rendu le superéthanol
encore plus attractif sur la fin de
l'année depuis le mois d'octobre et la
début janvier on constate également que
l'écart de prix reste très important
entre le super éthanol et les essence
sans plomb 95 e10 le superéthanol est
venu plus de la moitié moins cher que
les essence classique pour faire face à
l'augmentation des prix des carburants
le premier ministre jean castex a
annoncé une réelle de 10 % du barème
kilométrique pour en bénéficier il faut
indiquer dans sa déclaration d'impôt sur
le revenu les kilomètres parcourus pour
se rendre sur son lieu de travail
du coup de pouce qui n'aura pas
forcément d'impact sur l'ensemble des
français puisque il s'agit des gros
rouleurs 1 cc gros rouleurs que ont été
ciblés qui ont été ciblés par le
gouvernement alors face à cette hausse
du prix des carburants des alternatives
existent et on va en parler avec mon
invitant visioconférence ça et xavier de
la porte bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
président du club climat énergie de
saint quentin en yvelines alors il
regroupe des entreprises des acteurs
économiques qui s'engagent dans la
transition énergétique et vous êtes
également à la tête de la société et
figurines confuse consulting sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
sans rentrer forcément dans les détails
mais si on doit lister les alternatives
les principales alternatives en termes
de déplacement à la voiture
traditionnelle quelles sont-elles ces
alternatives
ok simplement je suis pas président du
club primes énergie je suis le pilote du
club primes énergie et je remporte au
président qui est un élu d'accord de 51
des voix les alternatives il y en a et
aujourd'hui je crois que surtout il faut
réfléchir autrement que que les modes de
mobilité et que nous avons aujourd'hui
parce que quoi il s'agira d'
alternatives il n'y a pas que le produit
le type de véhicule que ce soit ou à
l'essence ou même au bioéthanol c'est de
réfléchir comment on va consommer son
véhicule que morand consommation
mobilité note différente je veux dire
par là c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est
dépendant du pétrole on a toujours
travaillé comme ça on a utilisé ce mot
là pour qu'aujourd'hui on peut repenser
la mobilité de manière différente avec
des usages qu'ils soient sur des
véhicules électriques sur les véhicules
essence mais peut-être sur les distances
plus courtes ou alors partagés des
véhicules de façon à limiter le nombre
de véhicules qui à un moment donné où la
consommation de 2 de son propre véhicule
aujourd'hui il existe des alternatives
simplement c'est des systèmes de
monétique différent de ce que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui et je crois que la
crise de l'immobilier du
duc au vide nous inspire le pousse à
réfléchir à nier est appliquée
différemment se déplacer différemment et
vous le disiez peut-être en plantes
emprunter sur un même trajet différents
modes de déplacement alors on va parler
aussi de la voiture électrique qui
apparaît peut-être comme à première vue
la principale alternative la première
solution quel est le coût aujourd'hui
d'un véhicule électrique en termes
d'entretien qu'est ce que ça représente
aujourd'hui le véhicule électrique
aujourd'hui le véhicule électrique c'est
celui qui coûte le moins cher en
entretien puisqu'on les déjà face à des
systèmes qui sont aujourd'hui plus plus
récent et qu'il nécessite moins mois de
mai câline et surtout le coup l'énergie
quand même plus basses même si on entend
parler aujourd'hui du coût de la crise
et qu'une autre sur c'est vrai mais je
vous donnerai simplement ratio en gros
on va consommer de l'ordre 16 ans
parlant kilowattheure pour une voiture
électrique de l'ordre de 16 16
kilowattheure pour faire 100 km ça va
représenter quelques euros si on parle
de dupes ou uniquement du carburant ou
l'énergie offert 100 km en est qu avec
un véhicule thermique
on va consommer de leurs 2 6 7 8 pour
faire 6 km au prix conclu aujourd'hui on
sera plutôt autour de 15 euros donc on
voit qu'aujourd'hui rien sur la partie
énergie et un rapport de 1 à 4
et à l'achat de ces véhicules
à ce moment là on sera toujours
bénéficiaire avec le véhicule s'est par
contre par contre les usages des
véhicules qui ne sont pas les mêmes nous
n'avons pas évidemment les mêmes
autonomie nous n'avons pas le même type
de 2,2 de fonctionnement notre union si
jamais il fait froid mais si fond ou
s'il fait moins froid et puis il ya
surtout une jeux de 2-2 de rechargement
ou aujourd'hui et encore beaucoup
d'appréhension vers le véhicule
électrique lorsque n'est jamais sûr de
se dire est ce qu'on va trouver de bord
les sévillans della sera en bonne état
où est ce qu'on aura tout simplement le
système de paiement ou deux qui nous
permettra de nous connectons voulait
vraiment policiers borne à saint quentin
en yvelines sur dans les communes
saint-quentinoise et dans les
entreprises s'y est ce qu'il y en a
c'est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il n'a pas
beaucoup alors il ya des réflexions au
niveau de saint quentin aisne sur
effectivement le fait de rajouter des
bornes maintenant la question qu'il faut
se poser c'est si on est des bornes ou
faut-il les mettre est ce qu'un usager
aujourd'hui il va se manger n'importe où
probablement pas il cherchera à se
recharger là où il peut laisser sa
voiture pendant quelques temps puisque
une recharge d'avec électrique dans le
meilleur des cas ce serait une demi
heure mais souvent ça s'est un peu plus
longtemps donc il faut privilégier un
défaut d'avoir une borne de recharge
chez soi c'est peut-être dans tout
simplement help us qui est privilégiée
aujourd'hui ce sont dans les entreprises
donc ça veut dire donner accès à des
salariés ou sur les espaces de multi
entreprises à des bornes de rechargement
pour véhicules électriques
il ya différentes solutions où
exactement ce qu'ils développent pas mal
aussi c'est dans les centres commerciaux
où là on se on se déplace pour aller
faire des courses pour aller faire
différents achats et on pense pourra
laisser son véhicule une heure deux
heures et demie alors on va recharger
son véhicule jamais simplement il
rajoute ça paraît important se penser
que lorsqu'on recharge on recherche pour
faire le plein autant lorsqu'on fait de
recharge dans l'essence ont fait le
plein dont on recharge contre 3 charge
de batterie de mariah carey on recharge
de l'autonomie on rajoute des kilos mais
nous on ne cherche pas à faire le plein
de ce que c'est une autre logique très
rapidement sur le coût d'achat à peu
près du véhicule électrique les prix
baissent maintenant
je sais pas si c'est vraiment une fille
les prix baissent par quoi qu'il ya les
subventions qui sont intéressants alors
il ya selon peu qu'on soit aujourd'hui
en achats privés où il ya déjà des aides
au niveau de l'état mais également quand
on est une entreprise a des ailes au
niveau des différentes régions ces aides
peuvent être comme significatives qui
peut représenter 20% du prix du véhicule
après on est plutôt aujourd'hui sur les
véhicules électriques c'est plutôt des
véhicules haut de gamme qui sont
forcément plus cher il ya besoin aussi
de développer l'attractivité pour ce
genre de véhicule donc les constructeurs
n'hésitent pas à rajouter des
dispositifs ou les aménagements ou des
améliorations qui du coup ne tienne ce
genre de véhicule relativement cher donc
après faut plus oiseaux nés en tester
aux entrants en plus totale du véhicule
ou sur une certaine période le véhicule
électrique est de toute façon beaucoup
moins cher pour l'utilisateur et sera
également évidemment moins polluant
qu'un de des gaz à effet de serre autre
solution c'est le covoiturage alors là
on vient en termes de carburant des
solutions plus traditionnelle après on
peut aussi qu'en voiture et en véhicules
électriques quand est-ce que cette
solution est la plus adaptée quand est
ce qu'on doit dire que le covoiturage
peut être intéressant pour nous alors eu
le courage nous on n'avait aucun effet
différentes études on s'est aperçu que
ça marche très bien pour les
particuliers une vraie appétence est un
vrai développement du covoiturage entre
particuliers au niveau des entreprises
c'est un peu plus délicat
l'analogique du déplacement des salariés
et simplement que l'entreprise met à sa
disposition le meilleur moyen est
peut-être le moyen le plus simple et le
plus confortable pour se déplacer sans
prendre le moindre risque donc de ce
fait le covoiturage aux entreprises
reste peut-être à des taux d'utilisation
relativement faibles avec une préférence
pour tout simplement sur le véhicule
personnel soit le véhicule le véhicule
mis à disposition par l'entreprise a peu
de l'autopartage apr entreprises pour la
notamment avec avec le nouveau projet
ski cher de l'autre portage péter
entreprises
l'autopartage interentreprises vous en
parler avec ce projet ski cher qui est
développé à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
expliquez nous le concept ça consiste en
quoi justement
l'autopartage interentreprises qui
s'apaise qui cherchent donc il était
fait au travers de trois entreprises
pionnières
la société inédit ce la banque populaire
val de france et la société léonie avec
le soutien des villes de guyancourt de
mutigny et de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines où finalement nous
avons mis sur deux stations l'une qui
est avait une centre et l'autre qui est
au niveau du pas du lac de stations de
10 véhicules des véhicules hybrides et
des véhicules électriques qui sont mis à
disposition des salariés de ces trois
entreprises et en fait on a une gestion
du maire de gestion de flotte ou
n'importe quel salarié de ces trois
entreprises peuvent prendre peuvent
réserver une manière indifférente la de
senna de ces véhicules pour ces usages
le choix est en affaires entre un
véhicule électrique un véhicule hybride
et ça c'est encore une fois sur les
usages que la différence se fera
lorsqu'on est sur un véhicule électrique
voulait plutôt sur des courtes durées et
cet équipement usage des listes qui fait
beaucoup de déplacements intra bureau
fera à trévise où ils soient des
distances courtes et quand vous prenez
les hauts niveaux la banque populaire
qui se dépassent couramment souvent la
soie des régions ou même pourquoi pas à
l'étranger là effectivement il ya un
choix vers eux vers le véhicule hybride
et c'est vraiment cette capacité de
s'adapter aux besoins qui fait la malle
la la la la singularité de ce qu'ils
cherchent très rapidement en 10 secondes
l'idée c'est d'être pionnier sur
peut-être d'autres territoires de servir
de bon exemple avec ce modèle ski cher
pourquoi pas ce modèle simplement il est
très fier parce que là on a récupéré un
prix qui nous était décernée par
l'organisme gestionnaire des délais des
flottes d'entreprises en france on les
premières de ce genre de prix qui
montrent que finalement une stratégie de
mobilité collaborative fonctionne et est
apprécié par les professionnels et donc
oui effectivement est-ce qu'on peut
demain le développer déjà sur saint
quentin en yvelines et pourquoi pas sur
d'autres territoires nous avons des
discussions avec même certaines régions
en dehors du territoire de 50 ha et
pourquoi pas avec d'autres
agglomérations proches de saint quentin
on a déjà entamé certains contacts je
pense que ça peut avoir du sens commune
quelques créer demain de nouvelles
citations voilà vous l'avez vu il existe
des alternatives à la voiture
traditionnelle et en plus de ça les
entreprises de saint quentin en yvelines
travaille aussi sur le sujet sont
pionnières en la matière merci à xavier
de l'apport d'avoir été avec nous
du club climat énergie de saint quentin
en yvelines
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité la large
baisse du chômage dans les yvelines l'an
passé entre janvier et décembre 2021 le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi de
catégorie à a reculé de 12,13 % dans le
département - 4 % pour toutes les
catégories dynamique qui est similaire à
celle observée au niveau national en
décembre on dénombrait 65 mille six cent
cinquante demandeurs d'emploi de
catégorie a soit quasiment le même
chiffre qu'en janvier 2001 2020 ce qui
veut dire que le chômage est revenu à
des niveaux d'avant crise sanitaire
focus à présent sur une start up de
création française création française
d'ameublement et de décoration
d'intérieur art et cosy a été fondée en
2020 à louveciennes par la sophie pineau
porté par le réseau entreprendre la chef
d'entreprise a même lancé son site
internet en 2021 justin brasier et
mathilde francou sont allés à sa
rencontre
c'est comme si je m'étais réveillé d'un
seul coup en étant mais bon sang
pourquoi je ne suis pas chef
d'entreprise à la tête d'arte et cosy
sophie tu es partie des lauréats 2020 du
réseau entreprendre yvelines il
accompagne les entrepreneurs dans la
création de leur entreprise soutenue
dans son projet elle lance en février
2021 son site de vente de meubles en
ligne des produits haut de gamme pour la
maison sa règle d'or considéra réconfort
les gens doivent être confortablement
assis pour les assises il faut que les
tables répondre à des cahiers des
charges on va dire de confort de vie
quotidienne de convivialité et donc
c'est réussir la gageure est la prouesse
d'allier des meubles qui sont
extrêmement novateur audacieux est
vraiment
la qualité d'un confort quotidien la
start up se place également sur la
décoration d'intérieur elle propose une
offre personnalisée en 3d aujourd'hui
sur arte cosy vous pouvez envoyer la
photo de votre pièce nous on enlève les
modes des dpn et modem des meubles qui
sont dans cette pièce on vous la
modéliser en 3d et on fait une
préconisation décoratives avec les
meubles de notre site avec ses modèles
art et cosy soin de sortir de la
standardisation depuis sa création ils
sont six à avoir rejoint le projet j'ai
aussi ouvert quelque chose dans mon
passé donc du coup je le côté
entrepreneur m'a toujours intéressé donc
du coup de pouvoir apporter un peu ma
mon aide à l'édifice de sophie et donc
donc ce projet art et cosy samassa m'a
tout de suite beaucoup intéressés se
sont vraiment impliqués dans le projet
même si forcément son ddd des horaires
et des heures finlande comme pas les
heures comme là on est vraiment dans le
lancement du projet objectif dans les
années à venir enrichir l'équipe et
ouvrir une cinquantaine de magasins en
france
autre entreprise créée en 2020 lors du
premier confinement bleu blanc vert
véronique et constance sont des adeptes
du zéro déchet pour lutter à leur
manière contre l'impact environnemental
l'objectif de leur démarche c'est
proposer des produits plus respectueux
de l'environnement et de la santé les
précisions de justin brasey
bonjour bienvenue c'est bien normal
[Musique]
société artisanale implanté au vésinet
bleu blanc vert fabrique des produits
d'entretien ménagers écologiques ont
zéro déchets des eaux nique et constance
mère et fille se sont lancées suite à
des problèmes de santé vous savez déjà
longtemps qu'on sait des produits dans
nos produits d'entretien avec ma mère
parce que moi j'ai des problèmes
d'eczéma et ma mère a des problèmes de
thyroïde et on voulait du coup faire
découvrir ces produits là notre
entourage donc à la fin du premier
confinement on s'est dit qu'on allait se
penser bleu blanc vert propose huit
produits ils sont réalisés avec peu
d'ingrédients une composition
transparente comme cette lessive
fabriqués à partir d'eau de savon de
marseille de bicarbonate de soude et de
cristaux sud alors là on est en train de
préparer de la lessive revoyez l'ol
chauffe et on va mettre dedans
le savant marseille naturelles ou encore
sega les là sont d'égalé détartrant pour
les toilettes
toujours avec quatre ingrédients
uniquement tout est naturel jusqu'à la
colle fabriqués maison l'entreprise a
recours à l'économie circulaire
l'emballage est consigné ou réalisés à
partir de récupération
ici rien n'est laissé au hasard jusqu
aux graphismes on a que du noir pour
éviter des couleurs al impression qu
est-ce que c'est très polluant les
couleurs a l'impression que je vais
faire attention à ce que pour une source
noir pour trouver en mono couleurs et du
coup le graphe de kiabi mais le craft si
ce n'est pas une impression du bowling
le zéro déchet un mode de vie qui tient
à coeur à véronique elle livre ses
astuces sur le compte instagram de bleu
blanc vert pour sensibiliser
je lutte contre les micro castille avec
ma lessive je n'utilise pas de plastique
et en fait je fais aussi attention non
seulement à la planète qu'on va laisser
à nos enfants mais aussi à l'intérêt
individuel aux gens à chaque et chaque
personne puisque nos produits sont aussi
sans matières toxiques donc bonne pour
la santé et c'est aussi très important
pour moi
dernier produit en date pour la marque
le stick détachant
à l'audience solennelle de rentrée pour
le tribunal judiciaire de versailles ce
mardi au cours de ce rendez-vous le
procureur de la république maryvonne
caillibotte et le président du tribunal
bertrand monnet ont fait une annonce la
création prochaine d'un groupe de
réflexion sur l'organisation des
journées des magistrats le constat des
conditions de travail qui se sont
dégradés en 2021 situation due au manque
d'effectifs et à l'accroissement des
activités pénale et aux tâches
administratives l'an passé 85 mille
plaintes ont été déposées concernant les
mineurs + 14% entre 2020 et 2021
augmentation de 28% en revanche pour les
poursuites concernant les majeures avec
à 40 mille plaintes l'an passé depuis 14
ans la batterie salle de concert à
guyancourt propose trois studios de
répétition entièrement équipée à la
location il accueille des groupes mais
aussi des diots des artistes solos
amateurs et professionnels peuvent s'y
rendre en moyenne une heure minimum 10 e
mardi au samedi est découverte de ces
studios avec céline charles
[Musique]
mon style
j'étais de toute façon
très
intéressé par le monde et la fit dire à
dareta franklyn voilà et du coup c'était
c'était ses morceaux qui me collait à la
peau moi je prenais des cours de jazz je
commençais en fait la guitare jazz à
l'époque je prenais des cours est donc
ça m'a intéressé d'intégrer le groupe
pour appliquer ce que je faisais ce que
j'apprenais en cours que notre but c'est
un petit peu sa c2 de prendre un
répertoire plutôt à majorité on va dire
jazz et blues mais pas seulement un peu
de pop aussi un peu de chansons et de
leur pensée et de trouver des idées
dessus pour les as de les détourner un
peu pour pour être un peu plus créatifs
ce quatuor aux rythmes jazzy se rend une
fois par semaine dans les studios de
répétition de la batterie de guyancourt
ouvert il ya 14 ans ils permettent à des
musiciens de venir s'exercer dans des
salles complètement équipée quand la
batterie a vu le jour je me suis dit il
faut absolument qu'on saisit cette
opportunité d'avoir un studio ici il ya
trois studios de répétition qu'on peut
louer à l'heure
voilà en groupe ou en solo ou en duo
sont des locaux tout entièrement équipé
les musiciens viennent avec
leurs instruments simplement il ya sono
sur place les amplis on a une chance de
dingue le matériel est de très bonne
qualité les régisseurs et toute l'équipe
de la batterie sont extrêmement
sympathique il ya une bonne ambiance
tout est fait pour pour faire de la
musique dans des très bonnes conditions
c'est la bulle d'oxygène de la semaine
pour nous quatre jeux pensant comme ce
sont une trentaine de groupes qui
viennent régulièrement répété ici la
majorité et pop rock ils sont
essentiellement amateurs en plus des
lieux ils peuvent bénéficier de
l'expertisé du personnel présent dans
les studios on a également la chance
d'avoir à disposition si on ne souhaite
des conseils prestations scéniques
composition il ya différents ateliers
selon les années on accueille les
groupes on
règle le le sont aussi besoin on peut le
on peut éventuellement les coacher
[Musique]
la batterie mais également à disposition
un studio d'enregistrement de live
disponible sur une journée et elle
propose des soirées studio en scène pour
que les groupes locataires puissent se
produire devant un public à la batterie
[Musique]
avant de vous laisser les prévisions de
circulation demain dans les transports
en commun le trafic des rer et
transilien sera perturbée par un
mouvement de grève lancé par plusieurs
syndicats
a la sncf sur les lignes passant par les
yvelines compter trois trains sur quatre
sur le rer a et le rer c 2 trains sur 3
sur la partie sud du rer b ce sera deux
trains sur trois sur la partie nord avec
un changement de train nécessaires à la
gare du nord à noter que le trafic sera
également impacter sur les lignes j et l
du transilien pas de prévisions à vous
donner et restez informé bien sûr sur le
site transilien.com
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant
nouveau rendez vous du 7 8 sociétés
mélanie poké posera notamment cette
question à ses invités comment lutter
contre l'abstention aux élections belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]
on